THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: NEW EPISODE OF OUR
DOCUMENTARY TUCKER CARLSON
ORIGINALS TOMORROW.
WE WENT TO EL SALVADOR TO LOOK
AT MS-13.
HERE'S PART WHAT HAVE WE FOUND.
>> THESE ARE THEIR CELLS.
YOU CAN SEE THEY ARE TIGHTLY
PACKED.
>> 12 MEN TO A CELL.
PULLING THEM OUT OF THE CELL
LOOKING FOR WEAPONS AND DRUGS
AND TATTOO NEEDLES.
WE WERE IN A CELL AS THEY DID
THAT.
PRETTY RANK.
THIS IS A BULLETIN BOARD THAT
TELLS YOU HOW MANY MS-13 ACTIVE
MEMBERS ARE IN CELLS RIGHT NOW.
427.
ACCORDING TO PEOPLE WHO RUN THE
PRISON THERE HAVE BEEN NO
MURDERS.
WE CAN'T VERIFY THAT.
ONE MEMBER OF MS-13 AGREED TO
SIT DOWN WITH US IN THE PRISON
YARD.
>> I DOING MY SENTENCE 25 YEARS
IN THIS PLACE.
>> ARE YOU STILL IN MS-13?
>> YES, DO I.
>> WOULD YOU EVER LEAVE?
>> NOT YET.
>> HOW LONG WERE YOU IN THE
UNITED STATES?
>> LIKE 10 YEARS.
>> HOW DID YOU GET THERE?
>> THE TRAIN.
>> Tucker: IT'S CALLING HUNTING
MISOGYNIST.
-- MS-13.
EL SALVADOR IS GETTING THIS
PROBLEM UNDER CONTROL AND THERE
AR